we were doing I think V for Vendetta and
Natalie Portman was on set and Natalie
was reading the book and was just so
riveted by it that eventually I think it
went to Lerner and then to Andy and into
myself and we all loved that you know as
a piece of literature but you know the
unfilmable part of it crossed
everybody's mind I think in the summer
of 2008 I remember reading the novel and
since then we had the time to think
about it and be scared or not but we had
just done perfume with Tom and we had
composed the music before the film was
shot there too was even a longer process
than that there we were really really
scared because we were pushing the
boundaries of our abilities quite a bit
but after having completed that
successfully I think our confidence was
a lot higher run all the run was big and
matrix with hip and I knew Andrew Mason
who's one of the producers from on the
Australian front of the Matrix and I
thought ah maybe a doorway into meeting
these guys is getting Tom to write a
letter saying we'd love to do a piece
for your latest edition of matrix and
Tom loved the idea so Tom wrote an email
sent it to Andrew Mason Andrew Mason
passed it on to the child skis and of
course they love Tom oar run all the
runs so next minute we're all on planes
flying to LA all directors are different
and they have different sort of
strengths and different weaknesses and
different perspectives and I think when
Tom came aboard he came at it from a
slightly different direction a different
writing style and when we sort of in a
sense mashed the two sort of approaches
it sort of actually sort of cracked the
nut Tom and Lana became extremely good
friends so I think there's a lot of
trust with the which house keys for Tom
on his decisions not not saying they
weren't involved in music they
often came in which sit there in play
stuff but they leave they left Tom and I
was pretty much alone one has it
originally bought it in for which our
skis and we brought it out and said well
right what we're going to do this is an
independent movie and you know once we
had the material there's a sort of this
great realization that you know that
material an independent film doesn't
quite go together you know we we were
very lucky people responded to this
material from all parts of the globe and
in the end you know that's part of the
reason that we were able to do it
because we engaged partners and
investors in many different places and
you know Warner Brothers always sort of
standing in the corner yeah it was a
long process and sometimes we write too
many main themes at this time we said
okay this is an epic movie we should
rather think Lawrence of Arabia or you
know Star Wars or something like that
and write themes memorable themes they
needed to be there because the Cloud
Atlas sextet is actually a character in
the book it travels through time all the
way through the through the stories so
it needed to be written it's also on the
screen Frobisher plays it on the piano
fly plays it - ass and it's omnipresent
in the score so we have essentially
three main themes that we all we wrote
in the spring of 2011 we already
recorded with an orchestra in Leipzig in
Germany and a choir it was a quite an
elaborate demo production so to speak
and then we came back to LA and Johnny
and I remixed did extended versions of
these pieces that already have ups and
downs the way film score has and that
became the temp the temp score for the
film so when the film as the film was
shot they were playing the music on the
set to the actors they were the editors
who were putting the assembly together
which was a four hour plus movie used
this music for
champing and then when we came to Berlin
to to do the final the final stretch
which was about six months long
we used our layouts from the year before
and of course complemented it and wrote
stuff that was missing structured it to
the film babysat the thing quite for a
bit so it's a very very different
process from your run-of-the-mill
Hollywood movie even if it's a big
blockbuster movie